there's a bunch of reasons why i don't
know what i'm doing with this uh
deciding whether to continue on with
serious or not but i guarantee you when
i decide i will make an announcement
by the way uh gary [ __ ] with the whack
pack gary i wanted to see how the whack
pack would react if i retired oh yeah
so he called them and said that i was
hanging it up that that's it the show is
over
king of all black saw my retirement as a
job opportunity
[Laughter]
it says something interesting about each
person here's how uh king of all blacks
reacted
howard hasn't announced it yet he's um
be announced probably later on the week
he's not going to be reciting
damn that's crazy all right
what are you going to do i got a couple
of thoughts i might be able to do some
stuff at serious but i don't know
hey man i wanted to like try to maybe
try to get
do something up there you know because i
mean i'm not doing nothing and i i can't
get an audience you know what i'm saying
so
that's why i was asking you for a
connection up there yeah i mean
listen i know that they have a lot of
money left over but i don't know that
they uh
that they're looking to to hire but you
know i could talk for three hours and
still keep an audience with no
commercial
i mean i'm not bragging but hey i
couldn't do it i did it
and and i'm getting my basement done
renovated to be like a studio
so the truth is that we've just been
kind of
calling everybody to see what their
reaction would be
the truth are you bullshitting the truth
is there's no decision made
i know it i know you [ __ ] [ __ ]
honestly
[Laughter]
good to know my body won't even be cold
before king tries
oh he'll be stepping right into your
shoes yes
it was difficult for medicaid pete to
express himself
you never know quite what pete is
thinking or what he
understood apparently maybe he didn't
even understand what was being said
howard is not going to resign okay
okay you know it's more religious
so i think that maybe still still had a
little bit of show in them you know when
do you usually listen to the show
at seven so are you going to sleep later
now that's a good
good good question you know take all
this in for
for a little bit and then um see what
happens
i'm i'm sad that everybody's going to
retire but you know
i mean i kind of thought it was going to
happen what made you think it was going
to happen
i don't know i i i i i'm
hard to put it in words right now you
know but did you have a thought one way
or the other that you were leaning
towards
that's a good question you know just
kind of confuse the whole thing
a lot of like hey pete what thought is
in your mind right now
that's a good question yeah everything
was a good question
even though it was the same question
sometimes this is the best pete as usual
had trouble hanging up the phone
as you know that's his thing he's got
ocd and he's got to be the last one to
hang up
howard's really not retiring he hasn't
decided what he's doing yet
now how do you feel i don't know what
you said
all right pete well thank you you're a
good sport you know we love you
hey garrett you look good at foxy again
always good to talk to you pete we love
you
um i'll see you now i'll see you soon
and talk to you soon
okay all right you can hang up whatever
you want
sounds good guy take care i'll talk to
you soon
see you soon too all right all right
thanks eric all right see you later
all right all right yeah all right take
care
you can go you can leave whenever you
want pete i'll be rolling i know
so do you know how to shut this off pete
do you know how to shut this off i think
so
so i'll just wait for you to turn it off
then all right all right take care
all right jared good to see you yep
he's saying i'll see you and talk to you
soon gary no
when howard leaves gary won't be calling
you anymore pete
you don't know that i've never seen two
people more alike than gary and pete
both of them can't shut up